- Du hast sie gefunden?
Wo war das denn? Welche Straße war das?
- Die Tasche stand einfach so auf der
Straße vor einem großen Haus.
Das ist ein cooles T-Shirt!
Und du hast tolle Mützen!
- Danke!
- Du trägst gerne Mützen, hm?
- Ja, sehr gern.
- Und welche Farbe magst du
am liebsten? Blau? Grün?
- Grün, das ist meine Lieblingsfarbe.
- Ja, stimmt. Du hast ziemlich
viele grüne Sachen:
Das T-Shirt ist grün. Dieses Hemd ist grün.
Und dieses hier auch.
- Mein warmer Pullover
ist nicht in der Tasche.
- Pullover?
- Ja. Er ist weg.
- Welchen Pullover meinst du?
Diesen Pullover hier?
- Nein, das ist nicht mein warmer Pullover.
- Ist denn sonst alles da?
- Pass und Handy …
Mein Hemd, ich hatte ein buntes Hemd.
Das ist auch weg.
Das war mein Lieblingshemd.
- Ich habe eine Idee: Wir gehen in die
Stadt und du kaufst dir ein neues Hemd
und einen warmen Pullover. Hast du Lust?
Ich weiß, wo man günstig einkaufen kann.
Ich habe auch nicht viel Geld.
- Ja, sehr gerne!
- Cool!